and now we take the Pulse of the nation
While most tend to analyze the 2024
election as a race between Biden and
most likely Donald Trump we cannot lose
sight of the X factors here meaning
third party candidates a new USA today's
suffk University poll has the Front
Runners Biden and Trump tied at 37 but
independent candidate RFK Jr has a not
unimpressive
133% now the shock here is that some of
his support is coming from voters who
would otherwise support Trump now
Cornell West he's also in the mix
peeling off some Biden voters but West
is only polling at about 4% joining me
now someone very familiar with third
party candidates an old friend Ed
Rollins campaign co-manager for Ross
peros 92 independent presidential bid he
also was a campaign manager for one of
the last great presidential campaigns
Reagan 84 I still have my t-shirt Ed
great to see you tonight um now a lot of
a lot of polls show a narrow margin
between Trump and Biden could either of
these candidates end up costing uh one
of them the election West or RFK
Jr sure everybody has to be very aware
today that there's a real polarization
in the country uh and people don't
particularly like the parties the
parties don't have the they're not
growing they're not prospering people
aren't going out and registering and to
a certain extent you're going to have
two candidates running again I think I
think it's going to be Biden and I think
it's going to be Trump that the country
does not necessarily want either party
doesn't want it and Biden's numbers for
an income the president are terrible so
anybody that takes three four 5% away
can make a big difference uh you're not
going to beat them in the in the head to
head but you certainly could affect a
tight Electoral College which I assume
since we've run the same election twice
and literally one time Trump won by a
little more than 50,000 votes and the
second time be 100,000 votes so you're
really talking on a very narrow narrow
Focus here and Ed when if you were
advising both candidates let's start
with Trump I mean you're one of the last
great campaign managers alive in the
United States what would you say to
Donald Trump now given these external
factors that are also coming into
play I would tell him to run do his
court stuff perform any way shape or
form he wants to he's got a ton of
lawyers and they they have to advise him
and then go out and campaign on the
things that he did as president and talk
about what he accomplished and talk
about what's being undone every day so
run sort of a separate campaign from his
his legal he's out trying to make his
legal campaign and his campaign that's
not a winning strategy so focus on the
issues growth Prosperity low gas prices
Ed isn't the low gas prices something
that I I'm surprised no you know it's
not really being talked
about it's not being talked about but
more important I think is is the Border
I think the borders were things that
people Fel felt he did great things on
certainly tried to do great things and
that's that's certain flared up
everywhere and and again it's not just
New York or California what have you
people worry about that everywhere so my
sense is thatd be a big issue I talk
about uh the economic stability was a
big issue uh the military rebuilding the
military was a big issue uh and but it
has to separate he can't he can't go out
the key thing and I lot discussion
tonight I've been a fighter all my life
I've never been a hater uh I've never
I've never let hate get into my
environment uh because it damages me as
opposed to them and there's a great as
an old boxer and boxing coach at college
for many years there's a great advice to
referee gives you the start of a fight
protect yourself at all times and I
think we all have to basically be on
guard today there's a lot of unhappy
people around the world lot of angry
people around the world so it's only
going to get worse so always be aware of
your surroundings always be prepared for
who might might be in danger you in a
way shape or form and and people want to
get guns I don't I don't dissuade that
uh just make sure you're well trained
and how you use them yeah well it's
certainly uh it's a little crazy out
there but everyone should remember that
Anderson remember John Anderson was
polling what at 24% back in 1980 but
then election day he only got 6% of the
vote remember so that that ended up
being a big flop real quick well Ross
Ross perau in June of of uh the election
he was ahead of all head of both Bush
and and Clinton he was at uh 39% and he
he dropped he didn't run a good campaign
he didn't know how to run a campaign
yeah and it was very hard to try and get
him on on but the reality is I assume
Kennedy Kennedy will have some of his
numbers I don't think they'll stay well
Ed it's great to see you tonight as
always and always the optimistic Warrior
that's why I love Ed Rollins hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else